Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
Hey friends and welcome back to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Today we are going to jump into a clinical subject and discuss patient assessment in
critical care transport.
The background on this is that we've gotten the question a handful of times from our nursing
friends, how do you know what to do when you get a sick patient?
EMS folks across the board are pretty good at managing the initial steps in assessing
and treating critically ill or injured patients due to the specific way we teach and practice
patient assessment.
This is somewhat different than the way nurses are taught assessment.
EMS offers an algorithmic approach to patient assessment that is fairly consistent across
different programs and institutions.
It guides clinicians in the initial approach to both trauma and medical patients presenting
on scene with acute injuries or illness.
The nursing field, on the other hand, is a bit less consistent in its approach to patient
assessment and tends to teach it via a collection of different components, one of which is the
systems-based approach.
That said, this method of organizing a patient assessment and some of the specific components
do have value in the CCT world.
The general idea with this episode is to explain how patient assessment in EMS works for those
who are unfamiliar with it and then to do the same for one of the ways assessment is
taught in nursing.
Both approaches have value and the end result is a sort of hybrid that works well in the
critical care transport setting.
We'll also mention some strategies for practice and betterment so that listeners can dial
in their assessment techniques.
The foundation of patient assessment in EMS comes from a template used by the National
Registry of EMTs to evaluate EMS providers during a cycle motor assessment for initial
certification.
The way it works is that the inner EMT has a skill sheet that proctors use to verify
competency as EMS students move through the assessment and management of patients in simulated
scenarios.
They basically mark off line items in a checklist and a score is determined by how many of those
things are performed correctly.
Now, this approach as both a learning tool and a method for the evaluation of entry-level
providers has come under scrutiny, but the point still stands that the vast majority
of EMS programs utilize this framework to teach patient assessment.
And the result of this is that most EMS providers use, or were at least taught during initial
training, a similar sequence of steps for patient assessment.
It's probably easier to appreciate how this works in a video format, so we'll add some
links in the show notes for those who are interested.
But here's our audio version of how it all works.
We'll start with an unresponsive trauma assessment and then can discuss the differences for medical
patients and responsive trauma patients in just a second.
The first step is the Scene Size Up or Scene Survey, a series of steps that happens even
before patient contact is made.
Scene Safety and BSI is the initial catchphrase most often heard.
It includes ensuring that the scene is safe for EMS providers to operate in and then utilizing
body substance isolation, BSI, techniques to protect oneself.
This essentially means putting on gloves, but also considering other PPE as appropriate.
Next, we consider Mechanism of Injury or Nature of Illness, how the patient in question transitioned
from normal human to patient, i.e. what happened to them to prompt our arrival on scene.
After that is Number of Patients.
We want to avoid missing patients by focusing only on the first thing we see on scene.
Then we consider the need for additional resources.
This could be more ambulances, air medical, fire and rescue, law enforcement, technical
rescue, whatever might be necessary.
All of these things are subject to change as new information becomes available, but
the thought here is to think about them all early on before we get distracted by patient
care.
And then lastly, we want to consider the need for cervical spine precautions, whether that
be immobilization for those stuck in the past or spinal motion restriction for the cool
kids.
After the Scene Size Up or Scene Survey is the Primary Assessment, Primary Survey or
Initial Assessment.
All these names refer to the same thing.
First step is to form a general impression as we enter the scene and lay eyes on the
patient.
This is often described as the initial sick or not sick determination and is based solely
on how the patient looks at first sight.
This is similar to the idea of the Across the Room Assessment for Pediatric, referred
to as the Pediatric Assessment Triangle in PALS.
We'll come back to that idea later on.
After that, we introduce ourselves and determine a level of responsiveness or consciousness.
Next it's to figure out what is going on with the patient by either asking them or
looking for immediately life-threatening injuries.
And then we move into the classic ABCs, airway, breathing and circulation.
Airway entails opening the airway if needed and placing an NPA or OPA as indicated.
Breathing includes assessing breathing, ensuring adequate ventilation, providing oxygen and
then fixing things that might obstruct breathing, such as decompressing attention pneumothorax.
And then circulation involves three assessments, checking a pulse, rate, rhythm and quality,
checking the skin, color, temperature and condition, and performing a blood sweep.
The blood sweep is where we expose the patient and check for life-threatening bleeds that
we missed earlier on in the assessment.
And if noted, we treat those immediately.
Circulation also includes treating for shock.
The specifics of that vary depending on the level of the provider, but at a minimum we
teach to keep the patient warm.
And then the last step in the primary is to determine a transport priority.
This is essentially deciding if the patient needs to get moving as soon as possible or
if there's time to complete an assessment and perform interventions on scene prior to
transport.
Next on the NREMT assessment for trauma patient is to get vital signs and obtain what we call
a sample history.
Final signs should be familiar to everyone listening.
Sample is a mnemonic to walk us through specific things we want to know about a patient's.
It stands for signs and symptoms, allergies, medications, past medical history, last oral
intake and events leading up to the incident.
It's a simple way for us to gather some basic need to know information about a patient's
medical history and what is currently going on.
This may or may not be possible to obtain, but per the assessment checklist, we at least
make an attempt to do so or acknowledge that it isn't possible.
The final area of focus in the trauma assessment is the head to toe or secondary assessment.
This might be done on scene or it might be done in transport.
There are also cases where it never gets done because we get caught up with managing life
threats noted in the primary survey.
But in testing and in practice, we do work through all the steps, so we'll give a quick
overview here.
We won't get into all the details and, again, it may make more sense to check out one of
the linked videos, but this step basically includes getting our hands on the patient,
starting at the head, working down the body to the extremities, and then the back as we
roll the patient.
The idea is to systematically assess each part of the patient's body looking for specific
things in each region.
So for example, when we assess the head, the specific steps include inspecting the head,
palpating the skull, assessing the pupils for reactivity.
Some folks may also include things like peeking in the eyes and nose and looking into the
mouth again, which we already did when we assessed airway.
After that, we'd move on to the neck, checking to make sure the trachea is midline, assessing
for JVD or jugular vein distension, palpating the cervical spine at the back of the neck.
Then we'll move on to the chest, abdomen, pelvis, etc. on down the body.
During the secondary assessment, if we come across life-threatening injuries, we definitely
stop and treat those as they are found.
For everything else, however, we defer treatment until the end.
Things like dressings for superficial bleeding or splints can wait until the assessment is
done and may even get deferred altogether.
The idea here is to identify abnormal findings and injuries and to establish a baseline to
which we can compare subsequent findings on assessment.
So we work our way down the body, head to foot, go back and assess the arms, then roll
the patient over and do the back.
After that, we give treatments and perform interventions as we have time and as is indicated.
And that's how we do what we do, according to the NREMT and the skill sheets most of
us learned on.
A few notes on all of this.
First is that there is one step about reassessing the patient either after interventions or
in route.
Don't forget to do that.
Second, the value in a system like this is that it forces the user to look for specific,
different things at or in specific parts of the body.
But that whole approach hinges on sticking to the system.
If we deviate from the system, we miss things.
So either stick to the system or come up with a better system, which we'll discuss in just
a few.
Third, go back to the top if you get lost.
You can always start back at the top with how does the patient look and the ABCs and
then carry on from there.
That's a totally acceptable and an encouraged strategy.
Now, this design for patient assessment does seem to work best with the unresponsive trauma
patient.
So that's why we started there.
It gets a little bit weird when you have a patient with an isolated injury who is both
reliable and participatory.
It's also a bit funky with medical cases as the history gathering and focus assessment
make the system less rigid.
The idea there is that it may not make sense and it may be a bit awkward to work through
a head to toe assessment on a patient who doesn't need it.
That decision comes with experience and some outfits or programs teach this concept differently.
But if you're not sure, just stick with the system and do a complete assessment as outlined
in the skill sheet.
And that's often the way we teach it at basic levels.
Perform the head to toe on everyone in order to dial in the technique and ensure that nothing
gets missed.
For the sake of illustrating this idea, let's consider a patient who presents with an isolated
leg injury.
The initial steps of the whole process are the exact same.
Start with the scene size up.
Scene safety, BSI, mechanism of injury, number of patients, additional resources, cervical
spine precautions, then the primary survey or initial assessment.
General impression, level of consciousness, chief complaint, ABC's, transport decision.
Baseline vitals and history are the same as for the unresponsive patient except that we'll
actually be able to collect on it.
The next bit is where things deviate from the plan.
Performing a complete secondary or head to toe assessment on someone who is alert and
oriented when there's no suspicion of other injuries may not be warranted.
In that case, we can focus in on the region of the body affected.
If it's the leg that's injured, we need to get eyes and hands on there.
Expose, look, touch, and assess for specific things like pulses, motor function, and sensation
just as you would in a full head to toe.
If we decide that things aren't as expected and there is more going on than initially
thought, we can start back at the top or perform that head to toe at any time.
The medical patient is also less straightforward than the unresponsive trauma patient we started
with but in a different sort of way.
With the truly sick or unresponsive medical patient, we start with the scene size up and
the primary and then proceed to a head to toe or secondary assessment that goes systematically
from superior to inferior.
The only difference here is that it might matter a bit more whether or not we start
with the head to toe or whether we start by gathering a history to figure out the backstory.
It is important to note that this decision comes after the primary survey or initial
assessment where we hopefully identify immediate life threats.
That bit always comes first.
But at the point after we've done that primary survey, the decision is whether to move on
to a history gathering series of questions or perform a detailed assessment.
One rule of thumb here is that we do a head to toe first on the trauma patient and then
proceed to the history and that we gather a history first on the medical patient and
then proceed to do a head to toe afterwards.
You can think of this as an assessment triangle as it's taught quite often in the outdoor
medicine community.
At the top is the primary.
On one side is the head to toe or physical and on the other is the history.
The trauma pathway takes us around the triangle in one direction from primary to physical
to history and the medical pathway goes in the opposite direction from primary to history
to physical.
If that's tough to follow, we'll add a graphic in the show notes that might make it a bit
clearer.
And then if we have a more stable medical patient that doesn't warrant a complete head
to toe or secondary, we can perform a focused assessment.
A good practice is to always get hands on the patient even if it seems like we can figure
out the story from a well-gathered history.
And then the very last thing to mention about assessment in EMS is how we do the history
gathering bit.
This includes two components, sample and OPQRST.
Sample, just to review since we mentioned this before, stands for signs and symptoms,
allergies, medications, past medical history, last oral intake, and events leading up to
the incident.
It's something we teach that needs to be gathered for all patients if possible.
OPQRST stands for onset, provocation or palliation, quality, radiation, severity, and time.
We use that to delve into the details when someone is complaining of pain.
So for example, the series of questions might go like this.
Onset, how did the pain start?
Was there a precipitating event?
Was it gradual or sudden?
Radiation and palliation, does anything make it better?
Does anything make it worse?
Quality, can you describe the pain for me?
Radiation, do you feel it anywhere else?
Severity, on a scale from 0 to 10, 10 being getting your arms ripped off by Tyrannosaurus
Rex and 0 being chilling on the couch watching TV, how bad is your pain?
And time, when did the pain begin?
OPQRST can also be used to get details of a non-pain complaint, and there are also other
memory tools for specific complaints in patient presentations, but we won't get into all those
details here.
So to summarize how we do assessment in EMS, the system starts the same for all patients.
Scene size up includes scene safety, BSI, mechanism of injury or nature of illness,
number of patients, need for additional resources, and consideration of cervical spine precautions.
Primary survey or initial assessment includes general impression, level of consciousness
or level of responsiveness, chief complaint or life threats, ABCs, and transport priority.
We then move to either a physical exam in the case of trauma or a history with medical
patients.
For whichever of those, we close the loop and do the history gathering for the trauma
patient or the physical exam for the medical patient, and it's up to our discretion whether
or not a complete head-to-toe is warranted or if a focused exam is sufficient.
Patient assessment in nursing, on the other hand, is taught in a few different ways.
There are courses within the nursing field that do teach algorithm-based assessments
similar to how we do in EMS, but those tend to be specialized in the field of emergency
medicine.
The best example of this is TNCC with their extended ABCs algorithm to guide assessment
and initial steps in resuscitation.
We'll add a link to an overview of that for those of you who are curious to know what
that's all about.
But aside from specific courses, nursing tends to teach assessment via model much more focused
on either primary care or acute in-hospital care.
There are many different ways that assessment is taught in nursing, but one that is quite
common and of value to us in the CCT world is a systems-based approach.
A systems-based approach to assessment focuses on each body system one at a time in an effort
to understand what is going on with a patient.
This framework for assessment isn't commonly discussed in EMS, but is likely familiar to
anyone who has worked in acute care in the hospital.
It's often how we structure handover reports between shifts and units, especially in the
ICU.
A partial example of a handoff in an ICU might sound something like this.
We have Mr. Smith in 209, neuro.
He sedated on propofol with fentanyl for pain, occasionally gets agitated with movements
or turning, wrist restraints in place.
He does withdraw from pain and opens eyes to stimuli but does not track.
Pupils equal and reactive.
Respiratory, 7.5 ET tube in place, 23 centimeters at the teeth.
AC-VC at 18 and 450, 40 percent, 5 a peep.
Synchronous at rest, sometimes sugars with movement.
Lung sound clear, chest x-ray looks good, hope to extubate soon.
GI, decreased bowel sounds but did have his first bowel movement last night.
Was small and more continuing with his regimen.
GU, fully in place, clear yellow urine, responds well to his Lasix, and on and on.
No need for us to continue with all this as you probably get the idea.
We can then take this same idea and apply it to assessment at the bedside.
This is particularly useful during inter-facility transports where we don't have the urgent
need of immediately assessing a new situation for which the EMS system we discussed is designed.
It can also help on scene runs when somebody else has been looking after the patient for
a while and already has things more or less sorted.
We can even work it into our algorithm somehow after a history and physical or as a framework
for reassessments in route.
The basic idea is that it's another way to organize patient assessment in a bit more
detail when time allows.
But in order to do a systems-based assessment on a patient, we need to be able to recall
all the body systems.
Easiest way to do this is to have a reference card.
Another way is to have a memory tool to recall them all.
One example of this is Murders Inc. or Murders Link.
M for Muscular, U for Urinary, R for Respiratory, D for Digestive, E for Endocrine, second R
for Reproductive, I for Integmentary, N for Neurologic, and C for Circulation, both cardiovascular
and lymphatic.
Or if we are doing the Murders Link variation, L is for Lymphatic and C is for Cardiovascular.
Now, if you are making a reference card, it might help to order them in some sort of way
that makes more sense than the Murders Inc.
tool.
As we demonstrated in the example, handoff reports using the system often begin with
neuro, respiratory, cardiovascular, and then move on from there.
This sort of matches the level of consciousness and ABC approach we use in EMS.
Whatever way you choose to organize is fine.
The idea is that the systems-based approach is useful for ongoing management or accepting
a handover from another crew or staff.
The algorithm-based approach we teach in EMS is well-suited for initial encounters
or acutely decompensating patients.
Another thing we can work into the systems-based approach is management of all the machines
and devices.
This is particularly useful when picking up a patient from an ICU.
Some folks prefer to address this stuff after an assessment.
Some opt to work them into the assessment.
Others tend to divvy up the machine or device management and patient assessment between
partners in a two-human crew.
That's totally okay to do, but does lend itself to oversight.
Just be sure that things like drug doses on pumps, vent settings, output in containers,
etc., are all incorporated into our understanding of what is going on with the patient.
And if it helps to address those things during review of systems, have at it.
Just to summarize up to this point, we've got the algorithm-based assessment from our
fine folks in EMS that works well for initial encounters or acute decompensation and a systems-based
approach from the nursing friends for ongoing assessment or transfer of care from one provider
to another.
This delineation will not set in stone and definitely not to be taken as the one and
only way to approach patient assessment in critical care transport may help make sense
of things for some listeners out there.
No one system is going to meet every need, but this does seem to work pretty well.
Now that we have a general framework for working through this process in theory, the next part
of this whole thing is to get it into clinical practice.
One way to start is to simply memorize both the NREMT patient assessment algorithms and
all the body systems and, again, putting them to work.
Another option is to have a reference card on hand and get in the habit of using that
to guide clinical practice.
This works better for the systems-based approach when time likely isn't of the essence, so
maybe we've memorized the EMS approach and reference card the other.
Or better yet, let's memorize them both and also have reference cards as a backup.
We all know that memory is finicky under stress and we can plan ahead for that.
Another option might be to build out and record a script as we discussed in a previous episode
with Richard.
This can help us visualize working through the steps in a guided practice so that we
have a clear idea of how to work through these processes when on scene.
We've spent quite a bit of time discussing this idea and giving examples in that episode,
so if this appeals to you and you haven't yet given it a listen, definitely check that
out.
It was the second episode we put out.
And if you do decide to build one, let us know.
Would be cool to hear about it and discuss.
There's also the option to practice this sort of stuff in a controlled setting.
If you're a nursing person and new to the way we do assessment in EMS, get reps in on
a mannequin or a partner or a puppy.
Getting used to saying the steps out loud and physically working through the head to
toe piece of the assessment will help dial it in and build muscle memory so that doesn't
require conscious effort on scene.
And make use of colleagues with EMS backgrounds at work if you can.
There's likely tips and tricks to be learned from coworkers.
And then for EMS people getting into critical care transport stuff and new to this idea
of a systems based approach, consider putting time in to study up on each system included
in the assessment.
For example, when assessing or considering the urinary system, it helps to know what
a normal urine output per unit time is.
And also how this varies by age and clinical condition.
If you've never emptied a Foley, watch a YouTube video or have someone show you so you don't
spill pee on your foot the first time you try to figure it out.
Maybe brush up on how to interpret a urinalysis so that you have a better idea of what might
be going on with the patient.
Consider the different causes of hematuria and which might be relevant in transport so
that you can readily work through a differential if you notice it.
The idea here is that we can continually expand our understanding of each system in an effort
to glean more information from the systems review when time allows.
All right, a few miscellaneous closing thoughts.
First is that while the NREMT patient assessment skill sheets have sort of defined how we teach
and do patient assessment in EMS for some time, these things will be getting phased
out in the coming years.
This isn't to say that how we do the thing will change in any way, just that the way
EMS programs evaluate competency at the end of training programs is undergoing a redesign
and the NREMT intends to do away with the psychomotor exam as we know it.
If you're interested in learning more about that process, get in touch.
We have an in on the process and can facilitate getting your take and opinions on the concept
onto the drawing table.
Next, recognize that the way we've outlined things here is just one opinion on the idea.
If you've got a system that works well, stick with it.
If you've got thoughts on how we can improve our concept, let us know.
Other frameworks for organizing the process, such as March or anything similar, can also
be used.
Whatever the case may be, the last thing we want to be doing is entering into a scene
or transport without a framework for working through all the steps involved in the process.
Have a system, intentionally make an effort to dial it in, and stick with it consistently
and as often as possible.
If not, we will make mistakes.
It's only a matter of time.
Relying on one's improvisation skills in an unpredictable and potentially stressful environment
is not the way to go.
And then actual very last thing, and then we'll stop talking.
We mentioned early on the idea of a general impression from the inner EMT exam and how
that's similar to the across-the-room assessment and the pediatric assessment triangle as it
is taught in PALS.
That triangle, for those who want one last tidbit of trivia, consists of appearance,
work of breathing, and circulation.
It's a way to systematically consider severity of the situation when looking at a child in
the clinical setting.
This same general strategy can be applied to the critical care transport setting.
Oftentimes, it helps to stand at the door to a patient room or look through a window
and take a moment to observe before diving in.
So if we choose to organize assessment in this setting using a systems-based approach,
consider keeping that general impression step or even the whole primary survey at the very
beginning.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
But real quick, before we go, just a few shoutouts.
First is to Pragmatic Paramedics, another awesome podcast that we highly recommend.
Next is to the St. Fisher Church of Evidence-Based Medicine.
If you don't follow them already, definitely check them out.
These guys, both Pragmatic Paramedics and the St. Fisher folks, have been instrumental
in getting our stuff out there into the world and we truly appreciate that.
And then we'll end things with a shoutout to my good friend Josh Pittman and his buddy
Kevin Pons.
They put the music together for the show.
Until next time.